facture de la côte sncf l'a vu une
mission tu devais faire le guet désolé
pas par ma théâtre est dans une mauvaise
passe depuis un moment déjà et donc la
section tu fermes
non je monte un spectacle devine quoi
roulement de tambour
un grand concours de chant imagine ton
voisin le gérant du supermarché se
saouler qui passent là de vrais talents
venus de la vraie vie norman tu veux
bien leur dire que j'ai une très jolie
voir ses soeurs cherrier tu chantais
bien fou au fait le lavabo de la salle
de bains est encore boucher je suis ici
pour gagner ce prix je l'aurais chaque
habitant de cette ville a une chance de
devenir une star dans monte à
la gauche ça va oui ça va très bien
merci est fou aux seniors français
m
ouah
ce spectacle ne sauvera pas ton théâtre
il serait peut-être temps de passer à
autre chose
je vous en prie vous savez ce que ça
représente pour nous tu ne peux pas
juste chanter les paroles tu dois
montrer le fou qui te dévore le feu ça
fait longtemps qu'il est super bien mais
croire ce que j'ai fait aujourd'hui
là bas je veux pas faire partie d'un
gang genève chanteur comment j'ai fait
pour avoir un fils comme toi mais tu as
dis à papa à doses mais trouver l'argent
c'est promis
j'ai absolument besoin de leçons de
piano
oui c'était extrêmement mauvais un
moment inoubliable un tournant dans nos
vies je sais que ça va être très très
chaud non il y a
n'est ce pas la peur tu empêcher de
faire ce que tu aimes vous savez ce
qu'il ya de bien quand on touche le fond
c'est qu'il n'y a qu'une issue possible
et ce héros
tous en scène
le magasin se redresser fortement 15
minutes
hamon
villareal
la dame dans le numéro 6 et franchement
trop bien